[Music]
it happens in Kyrgyzstan once every 40
minutes a woman is kidnapped and taken
to a man who wants to marry her she
often doesn't even know him damira
Rhinebeck OVA has experienced forced
marriage herself at the age of 18 damira
later managed to escape she's one of the
few women's rights don't count for much
in Kyrgyzstan
but damira will not give up her fight
she continues to help women who are
trying to get out of forced marriages
and she does it despite a lot of
opposition from local residents
Oh
pretty much do you see I know we do
damira rhombic over travels around
Kyrgyzstan a lot she lives near the huge
is a cool lake about 300 kilometers east
of Kyrgyzstan x' capital Bishkek
from here it's just 150 kilometers to
the Chinese border
today dinara is moving into a new home
she too is a victim of forced marriage
it's called a lock achoo dinara has just
left her husband with DES Mira's help
dinara will live here with her four
children there's no bathroom or kitchen
[Music]
this is the only source of heat dinara
stayed with her husband for 14 years
until she found the courage to leave
open to new be occasion digging game
behind of Ghana it happened in winter
some men were riding by in a sleigh and
asked me if I wanted to lift they and I
said no thanks I'm almost home it was
manage it a little later two men grabbed
me through a sheepskin over me and took
me far away dan Tunde Gela we came to a
house and they kept me in an empty room
there were always people around I was
never alone for 10 days they wouldn't
even let me use the toilet by myself
they didn't want me to run away and my
parents didn't want me back they
couldn't afford to come after me so I
stayed my mom doesn't let that a droplet
open up just to suddenly dinars husband
shows up someone in the village tipped
him off and he's very angry turn off
that camera
but damira won't be intimidated look
down near the children's father you
should take better care of them it's her
fault she doesn't want to live at home
she moved out and got a job we thought
she misinterpreted Ayala hmm duping your
wife doesn't drink and she's found work
to support her children you beat her
I'll call the police and you'll go to
court we've got video that shows how
badly you treat your wife and children
dinara doesn't say a word she's
frightened her husband has beaten her
many times but she stands by her
decision to leave him still living as a
single mother in Kyrgyzstan takes
courage Gennaro will sleep at her
sister's place as a precaution it wasn't
all overnight
here take my number that way you can
call me just in case he gets violent
did you the main meaning hit for the
following day damira visits a local
cemetery many young women who've been
kidnapped and forced into marriage later
commit suicide there are no official
figures what you longer food you've come
back in many cases girls who have been
kidnapped
see suicide as their only way out it's
like a form of protest that's why our
aid agency focuses on this problem we
movies even brought the situation to the
attention of the United Nations this
isn't a cultural tradition it's a
violation of Human Rights
so Vania prageeta at the naruse any
approximately account
damira also provides support for my ram
she lives in the village of tube she's
23 years old and has a one-year-old
daughter she doesn't want us to show her
face few women dare to talk openly about
their experiences my ram 2 was kidnapped
and forced to marry the practice known
as Alok achoo in Kyrgyz means to take a
young woman and run away like so many
other women in Kyrgyzstan my RAM had
absolutely no say in the matter
yeah tabatha Trini I worked as a
seamstress in a nearby town and of
course I didn't know this man we met
twice about a third time we met he
kidnapped me no chromia he was 14 years
older than I was
everyone here knows that men kidnapped
their future wives that's just how it is
I used to think that was normal and
that's how I would start a family well
let not mind that but I just couldn't do
it
you told me ask your poached to move on
damira is visiting my ram and some other
women who suffered a similar fate but
they've got to be careful in kyrgyzstan
this kind of kidnapping is considered a
man's traditional right even though it's
officially illegal but the ban has
little effect here in rural kyrgyzstan
why we did it with an advocate it's a
football team we've got to help dinner I
find a better job so she can support her
children find her a good apartment
that's important by the wonderful
Jill was also present on the car and
does it also you know I bring along your
documents Monday or Tuesday then we can
at least try to apply for support for
your children
rosin just weightless you
since the collapse of the Soviet Union
Islam has regained an important role in
Kyrgyzstan most couples now choose to
get married by an imam not in a registry
office
damira visits the young regional Imam he
had a minute understood
dr. dr. o during a discussion at the
mosque the imam insists that he doesn't
perform marriage ceremonies that involve
- but at the same time he's expected to
observe local customs hyundai was a good
dose from the clinic for a little bit
there others again there's a new law in
kyrgyzstan makes it illegal to kidnap
minors for marriage to get the bus youth
and mom naked mom Nick so know your mom
would consent to such a marriage
corruptable need help but if he does he
has committed a crime under Islamic law
and he's I'm sorry
Allah every Imam in kyrgyzstan knows
this the close ones especially
puffernickel young Waldwick but this law
does nothing to protect women who are 18
or older during this interview several
men come into the mosque and ordered a
mirror to leave she isn't exactly
popular around here because of our
opposition to forced marriages a lot of
local men think that women should be
silent and submissive
[Music]
damira has heard that kind of talk for
years nobody has reported a single case
of kidnapping in this region
she isn't surprised what the Topanga
manuscript
girls are brought up to be obedient and
pleasant they've got to do all kinds of
work for their husbands and relatives
immoral this is instilled in them from
an early age notice distort ikuo Club it
helps to explain why women who have been
kidnapped don't run off a tidiness
factor of host honest iota
isn't governing so the kidnapping
continues despite the fact that it's
illegal
damira was supposed to interview a
policeman on the subject but at the last
minute the officers supervisor cancelled
the interview and in those rare cases
when a kidnapping is reported the police
hardly ever take action to them it's
simply a tradition is it war in the
silicon rape victims basically never go
to the police and use a country with you
it's a deal of the Govardhan when it
comes to bride kidnapping families tend
to sort things out among themselves that
would have to go long night Zilla but
all mostly it would be far too expensive
for them to go to court Brittani but the
biggest problem is that parents often do
nothing to help their kidnapped
daughters it's considered disreputable
for a woman to spend a night outside her
parents house no man would then consider
marrying her and often the parents don't
even want their daughter back Zegna prea
caller ID Chile leaders either the
parents don't come for her or they do
come and tell their daughter she's got
to stay because this is where the Imam
is and where the wedding will take place
this is Imam Musa Brianna Kia but
ideally said on they say she has to
marry the man and the young woman
doesn't have a choice when you visit
like a night time where can she escape
to buy dirt by itza Ana she's frightened
and stays for three nights billion
achieve a latrine Oh chi-su and after
that she can't leave because that would
dishonor her as a married woman animos
Oh pootie knows any vote so she stays
attached to a now drop above all azam
azam hasta Utzon
here damira is buying groceries at a
local market and she's talking to men
about the problem of kidnapping brines
it's illegal in de Oeste content
violates women's rights i'll bilateral
but usually the men say they to world
kidnap their bride every year fifteen
thousand women are kidnapped and forced
into marriage in kyrgyzstan and that's
only the official figure
you